hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Hogwarts
Legacy and DLC which stands for
downloadable content in other words
expansions add-ons upgrades whatever you
want to call it we're going to be
tackling the important questions like is
it happening when is it happening what
type of DLC can we expect the first
thing that I want to address is a quote
from Alan 2 lead game designer at Warner
Bros interactive which has been
circulating around the internet in this
quote Alan discusses the future of The
Game and his thoughts on the current
state of DLC the quote was made at the
IGN Fan Fest we've been really heads
down bringing Hogwarts Legacy to life so
at the moment there are no current plans
for DLC unfortunately the internet ran
with this a little too quickly as his
statement invariably sparked the
creation of thousands of videos and
articles in which the respective authors
so proudly titled their new piece of
content no DLC for Hogwarts Legacy ever
this is simply not the case Jew Milly
said that there are no plans for DLC at
the moment and this is completely fair
if we consider the infancy of the game
this absolutely does not mean that we
will never receive DLC that just
wouldn't make any sense whatsoever
around 10 to 20 million copies of the
game have already been sold this year
alone and the game is still only just
rolling out at this point only the die
hards have bought and beaten it casual
fans are just starting to get their
hands on it and the rest of the market
who I'm sure will catch on will
eventually be enticed by the game
regardless of whether or not there are
huge Harry Potter fan but the internet
does thrive on drama and click bait so
this is to be expected a response to
trending tweets surrounding a lack of
DLC was fulfilled by Paul Tassie who
made the following remark a better way
to frame Allen's response to the DLC
question is to remember and we've only
launched on half of our skus so far
there are people out there who still
don't have a game in their hands yet and
we don't want to shortchange those folks
this is a much healthier and more
productive way to look at two statements
and it's completely true the game is
brand new and hasn't even rolled out on
all platforms yet why would there be DLC
already personally I think we'll get
some DLC towards the end of this year
beginning of next year but that's just
my opinion a big factor to consider as
well is the scale of the DLC but most
importantly try to remember the DLC will
most likely happen and that most of
these articles spouting off about no DLC
ever are just trying to get your click
with all that said however what I want
to focus on next is the what what type
of DLC can we expect Hogwarts Legacy has
uniquely set itself up to seamlessly
introduce a lot of different aspects of
The Wizarding World from the micro of
Hogwarts to the macro of the greater
Wizarding World obviously with no
announcements for DLC this is all
speculation but here's what I'd like to
see starting with the biggest quidditch
the biggest lost opportunity of Hogwarts
Legacy is the extremely apparent lack of
quidditch there's a quidditch pitch we
can fly a broom and the game is an
integral part of Harry Potter law since
Hogwarts Legacy has inspired a new
generation of Harry Potter fans that may
or may not know the intricacies of
quidditch let me Briefly summarize
quidditch is a team sport played by
witches and wizards on broomsticks and
involves four balls a quaffle two
bludgers and a golden snitch a game of
quidditch is played with seven players
on each team and each player has a
specific position and role the objective
of the game is to score points by
throwing the quaffle through one of the
opposing team's three Hoops while
simultaneously Defending Your Own team's
hopes from the other team the two
bludgers are used to disrupt the players
and throw them off course the game ends
when the golden snitch a small
fast-moving ball with wings is caught by
one of the players the team that catches
the snitch earns 150 points and ends the
game given that there's a quidditch
pitch already developed on the Hogwarts
grounds this seems like an obvious and
inevitable piece of DLC dry was a
tournament the Triwizard Tournament is a
magical competition held between three
Wizarding schools Hogwarts School of
which carton was a dream bobato Academy
of magic and durmstrang Institute in
this tournament One champion is chosen
to represent each school and compete in
three dangerous tasks with the winner
receiving a grand prize these tasks test
the skills bravery and intelligence of
the chosen champions from each School
the tasks are kept secret until the day
of the tournament and the winner is
awarded the tri-wizard cup and eternal
glory given that Hogwarts is a
participant the fabled cry was a
tournament it seems obvious that the try
was a tournament would be included as
DLC the problem with this well it had
break Canon the reason I say this is
because the trial was a tournament was
discontinued after 1792 taking a
200-year Hiatus before being resurrected
in 1994. a try was a tournament in 1890
just wouldn't make sense and given that
the game has done such a good job of
preserving Canon so far I'm not
completely convinced that this will
become available other schools the
possibility for Hogwarts Legacy
developers to include other schools
seems to me fairly likely I say this
because other schools are mentioned in
the game and developers would be able to
capitalize on an area of law where it
would be much harder to contradict Canon
we don't know too much about the other
Wizarding schools and so this sort of
DLC would give them a lot of freedom and
when I say other schools I'm of course
referring to the long list of other
Wizarding schools across the globe not
just the ones from the tri-wizard
tournament these schools include
ilvermorny North America
mahutukoro Japan Castello bruschu Brazil
wagadu Africa durmstrang northern Europe
bulbato France and cordov stories Russia
if you want more info on these schools
then check out my video the history of
every Magic School in The Wizarding
World all 11 Harry Potter explained
bigger World The Wizarding World of
Harry Potter is vast and so I'd very
much like them to expand the explorable
areas if it was mentioned or shown in
the books and or films then I'd like the
ability to go there little hangleton
Private Drive the ministry of magic
these are all places I'd like to be able
to openly explore the rest in addition
to the above larger pieces of DLC I'd
also like to see the following smaller
things implemented either through DLC or
matches these things include subsequent
school years es67 interactive NPCs
craftable Polyjuice Potion higher max
levels more talents more side companion
quests consequences for using dark magic
Wizarding law implemented consequences
for being underage and entering the
Forbidden Forest the ability to become
an animagus Time Turner time
manipulation enhanced morality system
more spell variety Wizarding careers and
the ability to cast a Patronus among
other things of course bearing all of
the above pieces of potential DLC in
mind I think I can safely say that among
all potential new features multiplayer
would probably have the biggest impact
multiplayer mods are in development by
independent developers but as of now
portkey games and Avalanche software
have not mentioned anything at the end
of the day it's still early days for
Hogwarts Legacy and given the massive
popular Clarity of the game thus far I'm
sure the possibility of DLC is extremely
high and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel what DLC do
you want to see comment down below until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]